here's what everybody gets wrong about
manifesting
everybody at least kind of in the mass
market
what you're trained to think about when
you think about manifesting is vision
boards and when you hear the word vision
boards you think about the big stuff
should you have big dreams of course you
should should you dream of building a
mansion on the ocean if that's your
thing yes should you dream of the log
cabin yes if you want a lamborghini or
the new ford broncos should you put yeah
yes yes yes if you want the family if
you want the body should you think about
yeah absolutely here's where everybody
goes wrong
you
dream about the end you make this
gorgeous collage of all this stuff
that has nothing to do with your current
life
that literally as you're sitting in your
studio apartment with the cat box that
hasn't been changed in two weeks no food
in the fridge no fruit in the fridge and
you're looking for a job and you're
staring at a mansion going someday
it's going to make you feel like a loser
because the gap between where you are
and where you want to go it seems
insurmountable
and so what happens based on the
research is when you only visualize the
end game louis it's demotivating at
first it's really fun to like have a
bottle of wine and make your like
collage i'm gonna visualize i'm gonna
slap this up there's my vision for this
fabulous law of attraction baby come on
think about it it's going to come to me
okay i've been doing this for two days
i'm not i'm still in this apartment with
the cat box that needs to be changed
the way
to visualize properly is to visualize
the bridge
between where you are
and where you need to go the bridge yes
and particularly
the horrible stuff
so let's use your example of the
marathon
the vision board would be lewis crossing
the battle exactly
yes i did it exactly
that will not help you because when you
hit mile 13 on the actual race and it is
sleeting range you say why am i doing
this yes and it feels nothing like that
thing on your vision board you're going
to start a negative dialogue i can't do
this my knees hurt this is not what i
thought it was going to be i'm not ready
for this i didn't train for this i'm
running new york i trained in la are you
running in here l.a okay good well then
at least you're trained in the right
weather so on and on and on and you are
going to tank yourself
what you do by visualizing the bridge is
you train your nervous system
and your mind
to do the hard work
so you should visualize
not crossing the finish line but what is
it like to be at mile 12 when your
batteries run out on your earbuds yeah
no i'm serious and you keep going
what's it like when your shoelace breaks
and now your heel is lifting and you're
starting to get a blood blister at mile
17. what's it feel like when you wake up
and it is pouring rain
and you visualize yourself
running anyway
that way when you visualize the work
you are preparing your body for it so
you're not resistant to it when it comes
i want to explain something to you
that not many people really understand i
want to talk about the law of attraction
do you know that the law of attraction
is always working it's like the law of
gravity if i let this go it's going to
go down it's never going to go back up
it's going to go down that is the law of
gravity anything heavier than earth is
attracted towards the center of the
world well the law of attraction is
always working
now how does it work
well
i use a diagram to explain the mind now
let this circle represent your mind
and let this little circle here
represent your body
now i want you to think of this for a
moment
your body is a molecular structure this
is a massive energy and a very high
speed of vibration
if you looked at your body through a
microscope you'd see that energy dancing
right before your eyes and here's
something that'll keep you thinking for
the next 20 years when you move out of
it the body does not stop moving if you
go to a funeral parlor and pick up the
remains and look at it you will see it
moving and if it wasn't moving how would
it ever change the dust you move into
your body and you will move up
and it's how you use your mind that's
going to dictate the vibration you're in
now stay with me
you have an imaginary line right across
here
and that separates
the conscious mind from the subconscious
mind
now the subconscious mind has been
programmed
when you were a little baby this is the
way it was go just like
this subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there
and all the energy that went in there
when you were just a little baby form
something called a paradigm
now a paradigm
is information it's a multitude of
habits you are the product of your
environment but prior to that you are
the product of a genetic strain that
goes back for generations now i'm going
to say that the paradigm is x type
energy
now you've got the ability here on a
conscious level to think
and you can think anything you want to
think
and as you think you build ideas
there's a power that's flowing into your
consciousness it never stops it flows to
and through you you can actually
photograph this power leaving you it
flows to and through you
now as it flows in you will start
thinking and you'll probably think x
type thoughts
therefore you're going to be in an x
type vibration
and that will produce
x type results now it's the results you
want to change
and to change the results you're going
to have to change what you attract
you see the thoughts that you think
control the vibration that you're in
vibration is nothing but an idea it's a
law of the universe everything vibrates
nothing rests we live in a notion of
motion
and it's the thoughts that you're
thinking that you impress upon your
subconscious mind that control the
vibration the body's in
and that dictates how you act but it
also dictates what you attract
you attract energy that's in harmony
with you you attract people that are in
harmony with you you see everything
operates on frequencies there's an
infinite number of frequencies but you
and i operate on a frequency just like a
radio station does and the only music
you can attract is the music that is
tuned in to the vibration you're in
now it's the paradigm that has been
controlling the vibration
you can change your thinking
but that doesn't do anything you've got
to change the paradigm
and if you don't change the paradigm
nothing happens
now talking about paradigms is another
subject we'll do that at another time
but it's the thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in and
that dictates what you attract so if you
keep attracting what you don't want
understand this
it's the paradigm that's causing the
problem you can think a why type thought
which is totally different than the x
type conditioning it isn't going to go
anywhere
because when you go to get emotionally
involved and this is the emotional mind
when you go to get emotionally involved
with that y-type done the paradigm will
kick it out you know why it's so
uncomfortable
that's stepping out of the box that's
doing things different and we don't like
to do things different because it causes
a lot of discomfort
but understand this
the paradigm and the thinking control
the vibration you're in and the
vibration is going to dictate what you
attract
people that are in a poverty
consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind and you can gather
all kinds of information have you ever
wondered why some people have such an
educated mind they have degrees coming
right off the end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in their results
why
paradigm
the law of attraction
you've got to change this
you've got to change the vibration
you're in and your whole world changes
listen
in 1961 a man gave me this book and he
said do exactly what i tell you he was
giving me y type ideas it caused an
enormous amount of discomfort but i did
exactly what he said and you know
something
my income went from 4 000 to 175 000 in
a year and then i took it over a million
it took me nine and a half years to
figure out what happened
this is what i'm showing you
watch this over and over and over again
there's a number of lessons in here
first of all every time we have a
thought we make a chemical and and if
you have
uh an unlimited thought you will feel
unlimited and if you have a
self-depreciating thought you'll feel
unworthy and your brain instantaneously
fires circuits
that signal another part of the brain to
release peptides or chemical messengers
that signal hormonal centers
and when we get that arousal from the
thought that we think
those thoughts sometimes weaken the
response weakens the physical body so
it turns out that
the emotions that are created from the
thoughts are the signaling mechanisms of
the body thoughts of the language of the
brain
and feelings are the language of the
body and how we think and how we feel
creates our state of being
so it turns out that the thoughts based
in the stress hormones
based in survival those are the thoughts
that begin to push the genetic buttons
that create disease in other words
a person wakes up in the morning
and the brain is a record of the past
the first thing they do when they wake
up in the morning is they start thinking
about their problems and those problems
are memories that are etched in the
brain that are connected to certain
people certain objects uh certain things
at certain times and places so if you
believe that your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny the
moment you think about your problems
you're thinking in the past right
now every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them because
we've experienced them so the moment you
remember your problems
now you feel unhappy now you feel
anxious now you feel fear so the moment
we feel those emotions it takes a
thought and a feeling
a memory or an image an emotion
a stimulus and a response and we start
conditioning the body emotionally into
the past now the body
is so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating that emotion
and the emotion that person's
fabricating by thought alone the body's
believing it's in that environmental
condition
so if the environment signals the gene
and that's the truth
and the end product of an experiences in
the environment is an emotion
we're signaling the same genes and genes
make proteins and if you keep signaling
the same genes you start down regulating
the gene to make cheaper proteins and
the body begins to break down now that's
an unconscious process
so what goes along with that is the
moment the person feels that emotion of
unhappiness or whatever it is
the brain checks in with the body and
says yeah you're feeling pretty
miserable you're suffering and we tend
to generate more thoughts
equal to the feeling that we have
and so then we get caught in this loop
of thinking and feeling so if we can't
think
greater than how we feel
our feelings have become the means of
thinking
then we're thinking in the past right
and so we call that
the familiar past and then a person gets
going in the day and they start thinking
oh i gotta see this person i gotta go to
that meeting i hate doing this and now
they get in their routine
and a habit is a redundant set of
automatic unconscious thoughts behaviors
and emotions that's acquired through
repetition
a habit is when you've done something so
many times that the body now knows how
to do it better than the mind
so now the person running through the
same routine every single day is on
autopilot and their body's now dragging
them
into a predictable future based on what
they did in the past and they've lost
their free will
to a set of programs right so now you
have the familiar past and you have the
predictable future those are knowns
so the only place then reasonably where
the unknown exists is the sweet spot of
the generous present moment that is when
the body and mind are free from those
conditions so along with those emotions
that influence the same thoughts
people start becoming more judgmental
they start becoming more impatient they
start becoming more entitled
they start getting more afraid more
anxious more depressed and now the body
is literally being depleted
of energy because it's believing that
it's living in an emergency situation
and in emergency you tap all the body's
resources for some threat whether it's
real or imagined
and so then when you're releasing all of
these chemicals we are literally drawing
the body's life force and turning it
into chemistry and so for the short term
that's cool
but the arousal that's created from
those stress hormones
is a rush of energy
and so then people use the problems
and the conditions in their life to
reaffirm their conditioning or their
addiction to that emotion
and in a sense they become addicted to
the life they don't even like
and this is why change is so hard
so then when a person makes up their
mind to change and they say okay i'm not
going to say i can't i'm not going to
judge another person i'm not going to
blame i'm not going to complain i'm not
going to make excuses i'm not going to
be a victim i'm not going to talk trash
about anybody i'm just going to stop
well that works out really well for the
first couple hours
and the bodies saying you're out of
schedule you normally at eight in the
morning you're getting traffic and
you're angry then at 11 o'clock you
check your emails and you're really
judgmental and frustrated the body's
saying well you've been doing this for
the last 20 years you're just going to
stop today so now the body which has
been conditioned emotionally to be the
mind wants to return back to its
familiar territory to the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on
this is a good time to judge that come
on this is a good time to suffer it's
your ex's fault it's it's your it's the
government's fault it's uh
you know it's the weather what the news
whatever it is and if we
accept
believe and surrender to that thought
without analyzing it it slips by and it
begins to program the autonomic nervous
system to make those pharmacy of
chemicals
and so
that's when the person makes the same
choice
does the same thing
creates the same experience just for
that familiar feeling okay i'll complain
just so i can feel suffering then
they'd rather
be unhappy
than step into the unknown to step into
possibility and the hardest part about
that process
first of all is not making the same
choice as you did day before
and here's the payoff
you got to stay conscious
and not go unconscious and it turns out
that 95 of the time we're unconscious so
if you're going to stay conscious then
there's an element that also requires a
certain amount of awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so
the thoughts that they're thinking
are slipping by their awareness
unnoticed because they're hardwired in
their brain because they've been saying
i can't it's too hard my life will never
change it's someone else's fault those
thoughts have consequences in the body
so then if a person then becomes
conscious
of those unconscious thoughts becomes
aware of how they speak and how they act
and they notice
how they're feeling they're no longer
the program they're the consciousness
outside the program and that's the first
step to change so
there are
when you when you're distracted by your
environment and you got your cell phone
and your tweeting and your
instagramming and facebook and whatever
people do you're distracted by that
feeling
but i now know that if you take a person
and you say okay close your eyes
sit in the in the silence of any
external stimulation remove the
environment sit your body down like an
animal body is the animal tell it to
stay i'm going to feed you
you can check your cell phone you can
shower you can have your coffee but when
i say
and so then here comes the challenge
right so and and then
if you say then you're not going to live
in the familiar future a familiar past
or predictable future you're not going
to think about how long you've been
meditating what you got to do you you
labor
for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it
but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say i
think i'm meditating wrong i always say
oh no no no you're doing it right
because when you notice that your body
wants to get up and
check your cell phone or have a cup of
coffee and you become aware that it's on
autopilot and wants to do that and you
say
come on over here
and you return it back to the present
moment
you're executing a will now
that's greater than the program and if
the person
wants to just get angry while they're
sitting there there's an arousal and
they notice the body is amping up and
revving up and they settle it back down
now they're telling the body it's no
longer the mind
that they're the mind now we've
researched this
and it's tedious
in the beginning at first because david
is fighting goliath
but if you keep practicing it just like
training an animal
sooner or later the body acquiesces
sooner or later the body is trained to a
new mind and when that happens
there's a liberation of energy the body
goes from particle to wave from matter
to energy and there goes that emotion
literally liberated from body as energy
so the person who has the strong emotion
to some circumstance in their life
and they're
they're working and lowering the volume
of that emotion the more they lower the
volume of that emotion the more they're
going to take their attention off that
person and problem and they're gonna
take their power back there's gonna be a
break
in their attention from that
circumstance and now they build their
own field and now there's energy to heal
now there's energy to create a new life
now there's energy for the mystical
moment because they've overcome their
old personality self so
i think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message it's
it's overcoming
overcoming
overcoming overcoming until we become
somebody else and when that occurs and
the person starts thinking differently
and they start acting differently
and they start feeling differently
they're a new personality and yeah they
start seeing those synchronicities and
serendipities now
crossing that river of change
the creative process now gets exciting
because what thoughts do you want to
fire in wire in your brain what kind of
attention and intention something you
look at in spontaneous evolution too is
how
science and spirituality are coming
together they used to be very separate
absolutely there's the scientific world
which is very factual driven and that's
that and you couldn't change it and
spirituality was trying to open up
things but they really are meeting now
aren't they yeah it was interesting
because um the spiritual world of
religion was talking about the invisible
moving forces that shape the physical
reality and we call them spirit
and then science uh
only came into existence because it made
a detent with the church in the very
early days of science it said look we
won't tread on your invisible spiritual
domain we will just study the physical
world and when newton was able to
predict the movements of the planet by
just looking at the physical features
then scientists got the ideas well if
you can understand how the universe
operates by just stunning the material
world we don't need that invisible stuff
but in 1925
newtonian physics was
incorporated subsumed by a bigger
physics called quantum physics and
quantum physics emphasizes the universe
is made out of energy it's not made out
of matter and then i say well what does
the quantum physicists call this energy
that the universe is made out of i say
well they call it the field i said
what's the definition of the field i
love this
invisible moving forces that influence
the physical world i go
my goodness that's the same definition
as spiritual it's used for spirit i go
yes quantum physics emphasizing the
invisible uh field as primary to the
physical world
is essentially reiterating
the statement of the spiritual people
who talked about the invisible forces
shaping our physical existence and so by
definition
science the new science of quantum
physics is bringing us back into
alignment with the spiritual reality
hopefully
the the dogmatic beliefs of the church
which had uh talked about these
wonderful terms but didn't allow us to
live there
and science which is still stuck in its
material plane will both divest
themselves of their dogma
and allow us to come together and
recognize that we're all
part of that invisible field that
we don't even live in our own bodies if
you understand the nature of how the
cell works that we are part of the field
being downloaded into our body that
we're all by definition the field or
we're all spiritual same definition
and and if we recognize this the unity
of it and that you cannot be taken out
of the field and you cannot be in a
sense punished by the field you are the
field
then maybe the beliefs those very
restrictive beliefs from both science
and from the dogmatic religion
uh will disappear
because the people owning their own
spirituality owning their own
responsibility
and not saying oh which spirits that did
this or things other factors that we are
the creators
will generate a new world because what i
firmly believe is very simple go out and
talk to the average person anywhere in
the world and so if you could create a
world what would you like well i'd like
a world where there's peace and harmony
and i like some food and a job and i go
isn't it amazing how everywhere you go
in the world virtually entire population
has the same belief i go then how come
we don't have any answers because the
leadership isn't exercising that belief
so i trust the people
to take over the leadership of this
world
and that the structure that is is
actually in a state of collapse when it
collapses this will be our opportunity
to evolve from the very destructive
darwinian perception of a world
into a more holistic holism that says
we're all part of the same system we're
all cells in the same body and when we
work together
we will create magic on this earth like
nothing has ever been seen before so i'm
very optimistic about that we can refuse
to think certain thoughts
look how often you have refused to think
a positive thought about yourself
well
you can also refuse to think a negative
thought about yourself too
it seems to me that everyone on this
planet that i know
or have worked with
is suffering from self-hatred and guilt
to one degree or another
the more self-hatred and guilt we have
the less our life works
we find we have an inability to speak up
for ourselves and we are always trying
to please others
or we may be angry and explosive all the
time
the less self-hatred and guilt we have
the better our lives work on all levels
this includes the health of the body too
it has been my experience that the very
bottom line for everyone i have worked
with is always
i'm not good enough
and we often add to this i don't do
enough
or
i don't deserve
does this sound like you
always saying or implying or feeling
that you are not good enough
but for whom
and according to whose standards
now if these negative beliefs are very
strong in you
then how can you possibly create a
loving joyous prosperous healthy life
somehow your subconscious beliefs would
always be contradicting these objectives
and making sure you do not obtain your
goals
i find that resentment criticism guilt
and fear
cause more problems in our bodies and in
our experiences than anything else
these feelings come from blaming others
and not taking responsibility
for our own lives
you see if we are all one hundred
percent responsible for everything in
our lives
then there is no one to blame
whatever is happening out there is only
a mirror of our own inner thinking
i am not condoning other people's poor
behavior
but we must realize it is our beliefs
that attract to us
people that will treat us that way
if you find yourself saying everyone
always does such and such to me
criticizes me ignores me takes advantage
of me or abuses me
then this is your pattern
there is some thought in you that
attracts this behavior
on some internal level you believe you
deserve to be treated this way
or
you treat other people this way and it
is just coming back to you
whatever we give out
mental physical or verbal
will come back to us
when we no longer think or behave this
way
the other people will change their
behavior
or they will go and do that to someone
else who believes they deserve it
you will no longer be attracting the
experiences you say you do not want
whether we want to change a life
experience or a physical problem the
place to begin is to say so
literally say
i am willing to release the pattern
within me
that is creating this experience or this
condition
you can say this to yourself over and
over every time you think of your
illness
say this with me now
i am willing to release the pattern in
me
that has created this condition
the minute you say this affirmation you
are stepping out of the victim role
you are no longer helpless
you are acknowledging your own power
you are saying
i may not understand it
but somehow i am beginning to understand
that i contributed to creating this
problem and now i take my own power back
and i
am releasing it and letting it go
what a powerful statement to have your
subconscious mind supporting
as i said resentment of others criticism
of ourselves guilt over the past and
fear of the future are the most damaging
mental thought patterns we can have
this kind of internal dialogue creates
and maintains dis-ease in the body
these thoughts can destroy the body
fear can contribute to baldness
ulcers
colon problems and even painful feet
among other things
criticism as a permanent habit can often
lead to arthritis in the body
resentment long held
eats away at the body and becomes the
dis-ease we call cancer
guilt always looks for punishment and
creates pain
the person's doing the vision board and
they're saying when i get my new car i
get my new house i get my new
relationship
then i'm gonna feel so great now that
well then they're back to the program
waiting for it to happen
for them to feel the emotion they're
they're believing their outer world has
to change in order for them to feel
better there's there's no
effect of drawing the experience to you
with that way
so
the person has to use those tools
to get them into the emotional state
for them to feel like it's already
happened now think about this
if you get up from
a creative process
and you feel grateful
you feel a love for life you feel a joy
for existence
you feel a passion
uh
to
for the moment
uh
you will not be looking for your future
because you'll feel like it's already
happened
it's the moment that we start feeling
those self-limiting emotions that we
feel separation and then we start
looking for it again well then if you're
waiting you're not creating you're
you're in separation again so then yeah
so then
whatever it takes for you to move into a
state of being and what is a state of
being
thoughts are the vocabulary of the brain
feelings are the vocabulary of your body
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being so then if you wake
up in the morning and you
come come back to your senses with a
clean slate and you say i don't feel
anything you say well let me start
thinking about all the problems in my
life well all those problems are
connected to different people or
different objects of things at different
times and places the moment you remember
your problems a memory is a record of
the past you're thinking in the past
every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them so all of a
sudden you start feeling unhappy you
start feeling bitter you start feeling
frustrated so now your body's in the
past so then most people then
create a state of being that's connected
to their past and if they're in the
familiar past
then they are going to crave the
predictable future and they're going to
fall back into routine
so then
we want people then to get very clear on
that vision of their future however they
do it and begin to combine that clear
intention with an elevated emotion and
the stronger the emotion they feel
from the vision they're creating the
more altered they feel inside of them
the more they're going to pay attention
to the pictures in their mind and now
they're remembering their future and
biologically it's exactly the same as
remembering your past in fact if you're
not being defined by a vision in the
future it means you're making your past
more real than your future you're
falling in love with your past you're
more in love with your past than you are
with your future that you're believing
in your past more than you're believing
in your future when you get to that
moment
where you have that feeling
that's your compass
because that feeling is going to drive
your behaviors it's going to drive more
of those thoughts and when you feel that
feeling and it's visceral
no person no thing no experience will
stand in the way between you and that
vision and and you will be initiated in
by the universe into wealth you will be
initiated into health you'll be
initiated into freedom those people
all those people that have healed
themselves of all those different health
conditions
they are so humble
and so happy
and they feel so great that they would
never trade this feeling
because of what you thought of them they
they've left that program behind a long
time ago they actually don't care how
you think of them they actually are so
happy with themselves
that they're no longer dependent on
anything outside of them now i think
that's a really important moment because
that's the moment we give people
permission in our lives to do the same
right and i think that more and more
people are beginning to figure that out
i will never work in a relationship i
just won't if i'm working in a
relationship something's wrong i'll work
on me
i'll bring my best you bring your best
and we get together and we celebrate it
should work it should work and if it
doesn't then i'm going to step back and
see what is it about me not you what is
it about me that i need to really look
at and change now
if there's a vibrational match and it
flows and it's fun and you connect
on
physically mentally mind body soul you
know that's cool i i think that's
healthy
but a permission-driven person can't be
in a relationship
where you have to keep going back and
and and trying to fix something i just i
just won't do that i just think that
when it when it's right it's right and
i'll know
yeah yeah so i think that i do think
that uh
relationships uh can be easy
and i i do think i i and i think that
they should be
and i and i think that if you're
heart-centered
uh that's a different place you meet
uh than than uh other emotions and and
and i and again every time i have a
mystical moment
and i feel that
transcendental love that i don't even
know the word for
uh every time i have one of those
moments i think i got this all wrong
it's just that it it's it is not
chemical it's electric and you got what
all wrong
well the way we view the world the way
we present i mean we don't see things
how they are we see things how we are
you know in every inner experience
that's transcendental experience and
rich enriches circuitry in your brain
experience produces
emotion or energy in the body so you
start having transcendental moments
where you start connecting to that field
its signature is love i mean but not
love like a love for your puppy
this is like this is like an arousal
this is i don't know the other word but
spiritual arousal yeah and we have we
have the evidence we can say
oh watch this watch this person's brain
and scientists are studying our work
i'll say oh um watch she's gonna pop in
a few minutes what do you mean just
watch she's gonna pop and all of a
sudden this person goes into an arousal
the sympathetic nervous system is so
switched on but the arousal isn't like
an arousal that from the environment
that produces anger or aggression or
fear anxiety or pain or suffering that's
survival in the environment that
produces the arousal this arousal is
coming from energy in the body that's
moving up into the brain and
the arousal is bliss arousal is ecstasy
the arousal is freedom
but it's it's it's not chemical it's
it's you'll feel it in every single cell
in your body now here's the outcome of
that
the outcome of that is that when you
open your eyes
and some conditioning some layer has
been removed
your spectrum of the way the world looks
broadens now because now you're wired to
perceive what's always existed
but you didn't have the circuits in
place to perceive them so then it's the
inner experience that literally trans
transforms our experience of the outer
world and so
when you start having moments where you
hit that kind of frequency or you have
those moments of love
you're less dependent on anyone to bring
you happiness
you're you're okay you can love the
person for the flaws
because you can see a part of yourself
you used to be that you no longer aren't
instead of judgment you have compassion
and you can encourage and and and
communicate from from a level of
connection instead of intimidation or or
competition or however relationships
work life is a series of changes those
of us who are rigid and inflexible in
our thinking often snap when the winds
of change blow
but those of us who are like willow
trees
bend easily and adapt to the new changes
if we refuse to change then life passes
us by and we get left behind
just as a flexible body is more
comfortable to be in
so is a flexible mind more comfortable
to live in
i am open to the new and changing
every moment presents a wonderful new
opportunity to become more of who i am
i flow with life easily
and effortlessly
[Music]
i now go beyond other people's fears and
limitations
i am not my mother's fears and
limitations nor am i my father's fears
and limitations i'm not even my own
fears and limitations these are only
false thoughts that have been hanging
around in my mind
i can erase them as easily as i can
clean a dirty window when the window of
my mind is clean i can see clearly the
negative thoughts for what they are and
i can choose to eliminate them
it is my mind that creates my
experiences i am unlimited in my own
ability to create the good in my life
life mirrors my every thought
as i keep my thoughts positive life
brings me only good experiences
there is plenty for everyone including
me
there is so much food on this planet
that we could feed everyone
yes there are people who are starving
but it is not the lack of food it is the
lack of love that allows this to happen
there is so much money and so many
riches in the world far more than we
know
if it were all distributed equally
within a month or so those who have
money now would have more and those who
are poor now would once again be poor
for wealth has to do with consciousness
and deservability
there are billions of people on this
planet yet you will hear people tell you
that they are lonely
if we don't reach out love cannot find
us
so as i affirm my self-worth and my
deservability that which i need comes to
me in the perfect time space
availability
the ocean of life is lavish with its
abundance
all my needs and desires are met before
i even ask
my good comes from everywhere and
everyone and everything
all is well in my world
my life has always worked perfectly only
i did not know it i didn't realize that
every negative event in my world was
life reflecting back to me my belief
system
now that i am aware i can consciously
program my thinking process to have a
life that works on all levels
everything in my life works now and
forevermore
my work is deeply fulfilling
when we learn to love what we do then
life sees to it that we will always have
interesting creative occupations
when you are ready emotionally and
mentally for the next step in life life
will move you to it
give your best to life today
i do what i love and love what i do
i know that i am always working in the
right place with just the right people
and that i learn all of the valuable
lessons my soul needs to learn
life supports me
when you follow the laws of life life
will support you abundantly
life created me to be fulfilled i trust
life and life is always there at every
turn i am safe
my future is glorious
our futures will always represent our
current thoughts
what you are thinking and saying right
now is creating your future so think
glorious thoughts and you will have a
glorious future
i now live in limitless love
light and joy
all is well in my world
i open new doors to life
as i walk down the corridor of life
there are doors on every side each one
opens to a new experience
the more i clear the negative thought
patterns from my mind the more i find
doors that open to only good experiences
my clarity of thinking brings to me the
best that life has to offer
i rejoice in what i have
and i know fresh new experiences are
always ahead of me i greet the new with
open arms i trust life to be wonderful
i claim my own power and i lovingly
create my own reality
no one can do it for you
only you can make your own declarations
in your mind
if you give your power to others then
you have none when you claim your power
it is yours use it wisely
i ask for more understanding so that i
may knowingly and lovingly shape my
world and my experiences
i now create a wonderful new job
bless your current job with love and
release it with love to the next person
who takes your place
knowing that you are moving into a new
level of life
keep your affirmations for the new
position clear and positive and know
that you deserve the best
i am totally open and receptive to a
wonderful new position using my creative
talents and abilities working with and
for people i love in a wonderful
location and earning good money
everything i touch is a success
we always have the option of poverty
thinking or prosperity thinking when we
think thoughts of lack and limitation
then that is what we experience
there is no way you can be prosperous if
your thinking is impoverished
to be successful you need to constantly
think thoughts of prosperity and
abundance
i now establish a new awareness of
success
i know i can be as successful as i make
my mind up to be
i move into the winning circle
golden opportunities are everywhere for
me prosperity of every kind is drawn to
me
i am open and receptive to new avenues
of income
when we are open and receptive life will
find many ways to bring income to us as
we know and affirm that we deserve all
good the infinite source will open new
channels
we often limit our own good by believing
in fixed income and other closed ideas
opening our consciousness opens the
banks of heaven
i now receive my good from expected and
unexpected sources i am an unlimited
being accepting from an unlimited source
in an unlimited way i am blessed beyond
my fondest dreams
i deserve the best and i accept the best
now
the only thing that keeps us from having
the good in our life is that we don't
believe we deserve it
somewhere in childhood we learned that
we didn't deserve and we believed it
now it is time to release that belief
i am mentally and emotionally equipped
to enjoy a prosperous and loving life
it is my birthright to deserve all good
i claim my good now
[Music]
life is simple and easy
the laws of life are simple far too
simple for many people who want to
struggle and complicate things what you
give out comes back to you what you
believe about yourself and about life
becomes true for you it is that simple
all i need to know at any given moment
is revealed to me i trust myself and i
trust life and all is well many people
come to me and say i want to be a
millionaire i i and there's a great song
about i'm going to be a millionaire and
they read things like the secret which
says if you want to be a millionaire
just just wish it and it will happen
and that's not quite enough i've worked
with many many many millionaires and i
became on myself quite a long time ago
now never having possibly thought that
could ever happen when i was at school
i was going to be a nanny that's how
much i thought i could earn in my
lifetime that's what i thought i was
meant to be but then i worked with so
many multi-millionaires and billionaires
and i really understand
how to attract money how to attract
wealth i'm going to take you through
today
why you haven't yet become a millionaire
there's several things that will stop
you here's the number one
you don't believe you are worth it you
may want money you may long for money
but if you have an inner belief that
says i'm not worth it not only wouldn't
you attract that money if you did you
would get rid of all of it so if you
wish to become a millionaire you must
decide you're worth it the more
reasons you can decide you're worth it
the more you'll have that motivation
that fire that drive to go out
and make a lot of money the second thing
that will make you become and stay a
millionaire
is working out how much good you will do
with the millions that you make you see
bill gates what an amazing guy he says
that in 20 years
malaria won't exist because he is using
his money
to wipe out malaria that's an
extraordinary thing and he deserves all
the wealth he has for that reason alone
if you can think of something that you
could do or
the people you would help an impact by
becoming a millionaire the more reasons
you can come up with the more people you
can help the more reasons you will have
to become and stay a millionaire and
here's the third thing and this is so
important many people think well i'm
just going to float around and manifest
millions i'm just going to sit at home
on my sofa and manifest millions if you
want a job you go out and look for a job
if you want a new home you go out and
visit new homes you want a partner you
better go out and put yourself in front
of people and if you want to make and
keep millions
you need to decide what are you going to
do
to make those millions what gift or
talent do you have that you can monetize
you may say i don't have anything but
that's not true if you really take a
while you can find a gift a unique skill
set you have that you could monetize you
see some of the smartest people in the
world they don't invent a product they
take an existing product like james dice
and he took a hair dryer
he took a fan heater he took a vacuum
cleaner he took a hand dryer and he made
them better
and many many people take an existing
product to make it better and become a
millionaire that way it's not about
shall i invent something i don't have an
inventive mind i'm not creative
it's about an idea you may come up with
a new product you may take someone
else's product for instance shapewear
wasn't new when spanx came on the market
and became a
multi-multi-million dollar company they
didn't invent a new product well they
sort of did they took an existing
product they made it so much better
and you can do that too
but the biggest blocks i see with
budding millionaires are these things
one is
i'm going to be a millionaire i'm going
to be a millionaire and they just try
and imagine in the future and the thing
about the mind is the human mind doesn't
future pace very well
one of the reasons depressed people
can't snap out of it is because they
can't future pace and by the way if this
is making sense to you please like
please share please subscribe to my
channel show to other people who also
want to make money why wouldn't you want
to make money you can do great things
for others when you make money but they
don't know how
they've been deluded by these
manifestation rooms sit at home and chan
om shanti and money will fall from the
heavens we all know
that's not true
so if you want money you must be able to
visualize but it must be now you must be
able to think of
how you're going to what could you
possibly do to make money
remember that woman who changed the face
of a floor mop they made a movie about
her and she became a millionaire and she
was a housewife but one day she was
mopping her father you know this is not
really a good mark and she recreated and
reinvented a floor mop and
has made millions that way
but here's another big block you have to
work hard many people think well i'll
just manifest i just sit at home
the best plan in the world will not work
if you don't work
so people get this really weird belief
that people who make millions don't work
they just manifest it falls from the
heavens they float around doing a little
stuff here and there
and that's not true i work with
millionaires and billionaires and they
do work hard they work long and they
work hard on their way to success they
work a lot when they get success
of course they can take time out but you
see when you do what you love and love
what you do it never really feels like
work i love what i do
i do what i love often say i feel like
i've never worked a day in my life
because i love what i do but really
i have worked out when i've written
books i've been writing for 12 hours a
day
meeting deadlines i travel all over the
world through time zones giving talks
and sometimes that's tiring i plan out
my schools and i'm there teaching
but i love it so much it doesn't feel
like work but if you believe
you can be a millionaire
and not have to change anything or do
anything or work hard you will probably
never be a millionaire
you have to work hard you have to apply
yourself the best plan will not work if
you don't you have to have phenomenal
extraordinary
self-belief
and finally you have to put yourself
around other people who've made money
ask them what did you do
what happened to you you see i met wayne
dyer many years ago and you said
something always remembered do not die
with your music still inside and i
thought wow
i'm one of the best therapists in the
world and i can't die with my therapy i
mean i need to create a course make a
school teacher to other people i was so
glad i listened to him
and i've listened to many people who say
the same thing i didn't go to university
i didn't have a child background i
wasn't born into money but i had a dream
a vision and i
married that vision to very hard work i
kept going
please don't think successfully will
never get rejected they do but they
bounce back they come back they have
unshakable
unwavering confidence they have drive
and determination
so take a few minutes and just get out a
little notebook or on your phone write
out all the reasons why you would like
to be a millionaire
all the good things you could do if you
were a millionaire the people you could
help
and then decide
what industry you could go into you're
going to invent something create
something and some of the smartest
people create things entirely by mistake
look at what other millionaires have
done read some books written by
millionaires there are many
read richard branson reed felix dennis
look at some stories of millionaires and
decide if they can do it i can do it
this is a template
and i'm going to follow that template
and if you have the belief the vision
the work ethic the drive
and the confidence you will become a
millionaire what do you need to do at
the conscious level in order to get the
subconscious aligned when you're making
a decision
you're using your conscious brain so
let's say you make a decision you know i
want to write a book i'd like to share
my life story i want to share my
my passion my interests my lessons uh
what's worked what hasn't worked and
there's something within me that wants
to share right and the reason i write by
books i want to share i want to share
what's worked what hasn't worked and why
um so what happens if you make a
conscious decision
but at the subconscious level
you have
a disempowering belief for example so
let's say your conscious decisions i
want to write a book i want to share my
knowledge and skills with the world but
underneath the surface you have this
belief this implicit belief that well
who am i to write a book
what do you think is going to happen
if you have this conscious decision but
a subconscious belief
that
maybe you're not smart enough or worthy
enough to write a book who are you
right what do you think happens
when
that goes on in your brain and let me
let me just look at the comments so give
me a comment what do you think happens
you know the goal
that excites you to write a book or to
do anything
is going to release dopamine in your
brain make you feel good you might even
share it with your um your best friend
your family your husband your wife your
children i want to write a book
but what do you think is going to happen
if in the back of your mind in the
recesses of your brain
you've got a party that says but who are
you to write a book let's say you have a
job right now
and maybe you're happy
fulfilled maybe you're not
and you say you know i'd really like to
start my own business i want to be my
own boss i want to have my own hours and
i want to work 80 hours um
to make less than i do in a full-time
job because i want to work for myself
well what if you know in the back
subconscious part of your brain
um there's a little voice that says um
well what if you fail
what if you
um don't earn enough income to take care
of yourself your family the things that
you want to do
what if
it takes longer than you anticipate
so can you see how
these conscious decisions part of what
our brain is wired to these make
decisions
are backed in many instances
with a subconscious mind that is going
to hold us back unless we understand
how to get
our brain to work
in coherence so in addition to your
conscious
uh decision-making wanting
brain
if you don't understand the power of the
subconscious which is uh driving 95
plus
percentage of your decisions and your
emotions
chances are you may be having one foot
on the on the gas and another foot on
the brake so the conscious and
subconscious divide um is really really
really important when
you have a conscious goal
but you have subconscious patterns like
disempowering beliefs
uh i'm not good enough i'm not smart
enough i'm too young i'm too old you're
gonna have something that we know is
neural chaos there's a part of the brain
that wants the goal in the dream but
another part of the brain
that is going to fight you that's neural
chaos and a brain and chaos will almost
always divert back to its current
comfort zone
so if you have limiting beliefs
then you have to learn
how to get rid of your limiting beliefs
you decide you want to achieve a goal
but there's a feeling that you have a
belief that you have that you're not
good enough and
regardless of where you developed
that belief that you're not good enough
that is part of your subconscious mind
so
when you repeat the
thought
when you repeat the emotion and when you
don't follow through
with the behaviors necessary to achieve
a goal that you want to achieve
you reinforce
that neural pattern in the brain right
and a belief is nothing more than cells
that have connected that have been
reinforced
a belief is nothing more than neurons
cells that have created through
something called dendrite spiny
protuberances the little pieces on the
end that come together and connect those
are dendrites finding protubences um
uh dsps they're called and when they
form and reinforce the beliefs then
drive perception behaviors emotions etc
so when you have a belief that you know
is a disempowering one at the
subconscious level here is a really easy
first step trick okay
take that belief write it down except i
want you to do this in a slightly
different way and i want you to do this
because here's what what we know about
the subconscious mind your brain doesn't
know some uh the difference between
something real or imagined
uh and so
what i want you to do grace and for
every one of you that wrote down a a
belief that you have that's
disempowering you is put in the past i
used to believe that i wasn't good
enough in the past i used to believe
that i wasn't smart enough in the past i
used to believe
fill in whatever the belief was and now
i'm learning how to feel and be more
than smart enough to achieve my goals so
all you're doing
right a lot of people will teach
um you know if you have a belief that
says you know i'm i'm not good enough
i'm not smart enough uh because i'm too
young because i'm too old because i'm
too asian or caucasian or too tall or
too short i can't
but if you take that same belief because
when you when you use language patterns
that are certainty based language
pattern which means i'm certain about
this this is the truth
right and then you say okay
in the past i used to believe this is
true and now i'm learning how and you
write the opposite of that what you're
doing in the brain
is instead of saying i am smart
and your brain says no you're not i am
good enough and your brain says no i'm
not you give yourself a bridge between
the two
and this little
inner size using self-talk is in the
past i used to believe this and now i'm
learning how now i'm discovering now i'm
moving towards being smart enough being
good enough being worthy enough etc then
your brain goes oh okay
let me help you find ways to do that
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to learn to change your inner
programming with a powerful bedtime
routine check the video right there next
to me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there the first
seven years your brain was in theta
hypnosis
so i say you want to change a program
every night when you go to bed just as
your mind